[Music]
and drug-free influencer news don't know
anything about that submitted by lemon
on papayas popular popular kids at
school will be recruited as anti-drug
influencers in a government funded
project oh that's pretty cool that is
really cool I can do it since I am now
drug-free just saying thank you I was
cool in school and I didn't do drugs
remember that Saved by the Bell episode
when they were doing a drug-free PSA and
we find out the guys were actually doing
drugs which one I don't remember jessie
spano doing she's all like trying to
[ __ ] she couldn't handle her yes she
was pill popping mmm
that's such a bad look have you guys so
what's the worst drug that you've ever
crack crack crack is probably the worst
thing I've ever smoked
oh you smoked it yeah meth crack I did
everything except for heroin issues how
productive were you on it I thought you
would have been true right I was I was
scared of psychedelic even though I
popped a lot of acid oh my god the funny
statement of ever no why because people
keep telling me when you eat shrooms
you're out of this world
and they said ass it's not the same so I
kept doing acid instead like you see
trails and then you think a lot do you
did you write anything down no I was
like 14 so I was just experienced and
you were really young yeah I think it
really helped shape the mind of who I am
today
definitely [ __ ] up the chemistry there
yeah yeah but like you you're not
attracted to doing that now no well I I
think every single drug I've had a very
traumatic experience that forced me off
of it so I don't want to go back good
yeah
traumatic traumatic yeah yeah I remember
one time I did so many pills in one
night that he pills right so then I
think about 72 hours I felt that I was
super insane and I wouldn't be normal
again and I was obsessing over my
thoughts like I need to just be normal I
need to be relaxed and I
and sleep and it's imagined like like
let's say you go through a heart break
or you lose someone that you love and
you're in that level of depression but
you can't you keep ruminating on these
thoughts and you keep obsessing in
circles and you can't stop thinking
about how insane you feel and think at
the moment and now do that for three
days straight
[ __ ] yeah and then you go that's why I
don't want to do anymore I'm just like
oh my god I don't want to go back to how
that high felt good I'm glad that you
have that experience though because
imagine if you liked it and then you
know like that's I think that's all you
should be one of the influencers because
you can talk about that experience but
there are great memories crack first
time I smoked it I felt like I was
gaining every single cell in my body
massage and I was relaxing in the car
seat like oh my god are you talking to
these kids and you're reminiscing and
then you're missing out on that say let
me tell you some about crack kids that
stuff is poison because when I first
tried it I'm lucky that I never was
addicted to any of that stuff like they
say oh you get you gotta take addicted
in the first hit and I had friends were
severely addicted right and they're like
they ran out of money dad to break into
homes and steal just to get a hit I
never felt that I never felt like oh my
god I'm jonesing I need a [ __ ] guess
some guy I never felt that at all like
this is it like I mean it feels good but
I don't know I didn't feel I didn't feel
the need to it was weird
yeah that's awesome though and I loved
it open you are about sharing that I
think that's really cool so no one else
is done driving wait real a bit drug
experiences for him no clean ass
no-nobody
drugs experiences have been awesome
really good maybe like the after effect
of it oh yeah they calm down as always
were sucks but still the best time of
your life so even when you're coming
down you're like
I was pretty worth it don't do drugs
yeah dude Joe Rogan pushes DMT like a
[ __ ] dude that's the people kind
of scared to try what DMT
dimethyltryptamine or something it's
like the spirit right like people are no
it's it's it's from something else not
the empty is shrooms
so like it's okay no now you're making
me know you're supposed to look at frog
suppose no yeah ayahuasca is DMT so well
ayahuasca is the drink is the question
but then you can you can you there's
also a smokeable version where they
isolate the DMT and then they turn that
into a smokeable version it's ayahuasca
yeah right but the ayahuasca is like
like a drinking verb mentality empty
yeah yeah so I guess like DMT has
something I don't know why I look this
up but like DMT has something where it's
ayahuasca the only I don't say the only
way but it's a way for you to get that
effect through digesting it so your body
naturally has something that counteracts
DMT that shuts it down the ayahuasca
allows you to ingest it and get those
effects some chili I heard that DMT
naturally producing your body is I mean
so is every drug I mean when we take the
drug all it does is it makes us overload
on that sensation or hormone or whatever
it is that when the DMT it's the same
thing that's produced when you die you
know you see your life flash before your
eyes that's why when you're on ayahuasca
your life flashed before your eyes and
they call it the most self reflective
drug like you start from when you're a
kid and then within like that 15-minute
high you you're like transported every
single age every single emotional self
defense mechanism that you have built up
and it brings it all down so people
they're usually crying their brains out
while coming at the same time like party
yeah like it's like every single thing
on the [ __ ] same time really work
through their [ __ ] through that like
they have a spiritual experience and
then they just deal with all their
demons and things that they were never
dealing with and the part that makes me
scared is everyone that I know that I
don't have taken it they've told me that
there's no coming back from it like
whatever new person you just became
there is you cannot go back to the
person to become better I might respond
[ __ ]
grin so the holy weird [ __ ] is like the
three-eyed Raven so we know somebody
actually that well I feel you guys after
the cameras off but that this person
took DMT [ __ ] [ __ ] her up like she
oh [ __ ]
just went off the [ __ ] rails and so
there's like that's like the one part to
it even like scares me yeah so even
there's cuz you can't predict what that
drug is gonna make you feel so yeah
there's a lot of people that might get
something great from it but there's
still that risk that you dance well you
shouldn't take drugs and that's exactly
what they're doing here which is this
freakin friend okay we're gonna go I'm
like if you drink enough robitussin it's
a good time I have that alright it's
called Franken friends and it's funded
by the government and they're saying
that this will be run across 48 schools
and the West of England and South Wales
from September and it will involve five
thousand six hundred year nine students
aged 13 to 14 and these students will be
in the top 17.5% of nominations as the
most influential in the whole school and
they will be trained into there will do
a two-day training to have conversations
about potential harms of drug use with
their peers over a ten week period kids
yeah so they're pretty much just trying
to figure out like who is the kid in
school I have people listen to the most
now let's grab that kid in the school
about this is it's like sex education
and and like being say no to drugs are
probably some of the two most important
things to teach but the minute you say
no to them there's the cheesiest it's
like the cheesiest message maybe this is
a different approach I mean I haven't
heard of an approach like this where
you're using someone within that group
to be the influential yeah but the
reason why that person is cool cuz
they're doing drugs yeah it's not gonna
work I mean maybe it could be reversed
kind of like in 21 Jump Street or the
second version or the second one where
like a cool thing to do now is to be
vegan and to put your backpack yeah but
the cool thing to do now is dress
like if we don't know we're not doing
met coke is on a rise now dude like
everybody's doing coke now it's like
coke is like a new weed in prescription
pills stupid code is the [ __ ] new
waiter so why everybody five minutes
then you just have to take another line
and you're not listening to any
conversation except all the stuff that I
don't know about that but I just know
that it's the dumbest thing ever I hate
you know kids don't do coke we've said
yeah but dude that [ __ ] when your brains
develop those reading things that might
[ __ ] you up yeah oh man I did so much
[ __ ] from AJ it's an interesting 22 yeah
14 to 22 does your drug prime time
well I toned down around like 19 yeah
like this 2 is already hella smart now
imagine if you did do that why shoot a
bit like this [ __ ] genius I know that
sucks potential you can always try again
ok I know I always keep going because I
think the effects that I that I realized
that it had on me is my late
developmental like mold and all that
stuff stupid like copying that I did
when I was like for you this brigade
spring came I had some math to know I
did [ __ ]
like air fresheners like and computer
cleaners like all you did the gadelle
shoes subjet alas [ __ ] dude yeah dude
bro codes and it affords actual drugs oh
that was a dumbest thing and sometimes I
wonder to mike [ __ ] i wonder how much
more articulate i could have been i
don't know they doin drugs my brain is a
lot slower that I for sure no my brain
is a lot slower than it could have been
if I didn't do all that [ __ ] yeah I
think like when I started dating will
started thinking about my health like
fitness eating right thinking and ice
and in my uh I just is just starting
everything started coming together and I
was like oh [ __ ] cuz when you're on
drugs or on substances you're basically
like at a stunted level and you're just
living on impulses like an animal right
and I think a lot of adults you see guys
in their 50s or 60s they're alcoholics
like and they still act like they're 17
yeah yeah because they're just stuck
yeah and that's what I notice is like
once you get sober you give your body
the times you time to heal you start you
know living a sober life reading
thinking all that stuff and you're like
oh [ __ ] so this is how the most people
see the world yeah I think you're just
wanted though you have to like really
want to be at that place where you want
to be healthy you want to like you know
learn you want to grow as a person if
not then just go to traffic I wish I
could read dude and that's what I wish
man yeah we know what's a good anti-drug
I'm gonna tell you this a good anti-drug
is selling drugs drugs like a mother I
mean I mean you got to pick the lesser
of the two evils right yeah there are
more choices and okay honestly you start
seeing drugs not as a way to escape your
own boring time and you start seeing it
as a product you can sell and once you
start making money you're like oh [ __ ] I
don't recommend it I'm not telling
anyone to do this stuff I'm just saying
this is this is just my reality I
stopped doing drugs because I was like I
could either smoke this up right now or
I can sell this make twenty dollars and
I can get two meals I crack in the
Cordova street
yeah and I could be like I could sell
this that's three polo shirts baby
[Laughter]
I guess my defeat oolong teas ami my
desire for money was bigger than my
addiction all right there you go
different direction
yeah yeah I like that too
[Music]
[Music]